Les malades déprimés que je rencontre en consultation
entendent toute la journée :
“Mais prends donc
un peu sur toi”,
“Fais un effort”,
“Bouge-toi, ça ira mieux”.
C’est aussi absurde
de demander à un déprimé
de se bouger
et de prendre sur lui
que de demander
à un hypertendu
de baisser lui-même
sa tension artérielle.
La dépression,
c’est par définition
un état dans lequel
la volonté ne suffit pas
et le fait de prendre sur soi
ne va pas guérir les maladies.
Si ça suffisait,
ce serait formidable
et ça s’appliquerait
à l’ensemble de la médecine.
Lui, c’est le professeur
Michel Lejoyeux,
chef de service de psychiatrie
et d’addictologie
à L’AP-HP (Assistance Publique - Hôpitaux de Paris).
Pour Brut, il va s’attaquer
aux idées reçues
sur la dépression.
Tout l’objet de la psychiatrie,
c’est de faire la différence entre les moments
de tristesse normaux
et la maladie dépressive.
Regardez
quand on est triste,
quand on subit
un événement désagréable,
on est fâché.
Prenez par exemple
le moment du confinement,
quand on a dû être confinés,
on était tristes,
mais qu’est-ce
qu’on avait envie ?
On avait envie de sortir.
Le déprimé,
premier signe,
a une perte d’envie.
Ça, c’est quelque chose
qui va faire
de manière spécifique
la différence
entre tristesse normale
et maladie dépressive.
Le deuxième signe,
c’est la perte
de l’estime de soi.
Quand on est triste,
on en veut au monde entier.
On se trouve pas
assez payé, pas assez aimé,
pas assez reconnu.
Le déprimé trouve
qu’il ne vaut rien.
Et le troisième signe,
c’est la perte d’énergie,
le ralentissement
dans le corps
et le ralentissement
dans l’esprit.
J’insiste beaucoup
sur cette différence
entre émotion normale
et dépression.
Nos collègues neurologues ont diffusé les signes
de l’accident
vasculaire cérébral.
Maintenant, tout le monde sait aujourd’hui
que quand on est paralysé d’un membre,
il faut aller en urgence
à l’hôpital.
Je voudrais que
la même information
se fasse sur
ces trois signes :
perte d’envie,
perte de l’estime de soi,
perte d’énergie.
Quand vous voyez quelqu’un,
dans votre entourage professionnel,
dans vos amis,
dans votre famille,
dans cet état-là,
vous ne lui faites pas
de la morale,
vous considérez
qu’il ne va pas bien
et qu’il peut
et doit être traité.
Il y a une erreur
en médecine,
il y a une erreur
dans la vie quotidienne,
c’est de dire :
“On est tous
un peu déprimés.”
Quand on voit l’actualité, qu’elle soit politique,
enfin tout ce qui nous arrive, on est tous déprimés.
La réalité médicale,
la réalité de la psychiatrie,
c’est qu’on peut tous avoir
des moments de tristesse,
des moments
de découragement,
des moments d’agacement,
mais la dépression
est une vraie maladie,
avec des signes précis
et des traitements précis.
Donc, on ne peut pas dire qu’on est tous déprimés.
Certains sont malades
de la dépression
et d’autres pas, et la dépression est reconnue
dans la classification internationale des maladies,
comme toutes
les autres maladies.
Si vous dites que vous prenez
des antidépresseurs
dans une soirée,
tout le monde va vous dire :
“Tu devrais”,
“Tu ne devrais pas”,
“Tu devrais essayer le mien”.
La réalité
sur les antidépresseurs,
c’est exactement
comme les antibiotiques,
ça ne doit pas être automatique.
Il ne s’agit pas de prendre
des antidépresseurs
à chaque fois
qu’on est triste,
ça ne servirait
évidemment à rien.
Il ne s’agit pas de manière systématique de refuser
les antidépresseurs
aux maladies dépressives.
Pour être précis,
il y a aujourd’hui
un protocole clair
qui dit que l’idéal
dans le traitement
des dépressions
caractérisées,
c’est l’association
entre un antidépresseur
et une psychothérapie.
Pas l’un,
pas l’autre.
L’un et l’autre.
Quand j’ai appris
la psychiatrie,
et c’était malheureusement pas hier,
on faisait la différence
entre ce qu’on appelait
les dépressions réactionnelles,
où on trouvait
un événement,
et les dépressions
qu’on appelait endogènes,
qui étaient censées venir
de l’intérieur,
d’un terrain biologique.
Aujourd’hui,
dans les classifications internationales,
que ce soit celle de
l’Organisation
mondiale de la santé
ou de l’American
Psychiatric Association,
on ne fait plus
cette différence,
parce qu’on sait que quelquefois il y a des causes,
quelquefois il n’y en a pas
et ce n’est pas
en remontant aux causes
qu’on traite les déprimés,
mais en repérant
leurs difficultés
et en les aidant d’abord,
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu’après,
on ne cherchera pas
les causes,
dans l’ici et maintenant.
Quand on est déprimé,
on est exposé à ce qu’on appelle un faux ami.
Le faux ami,
c’est le verre d’alcool.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que le verre d’alcool,
quand on le boit,
va nous donner
un petit coup d’euphorie,
chacun s’en aperçoit.
Quand on boit un ou deux verres d’alcool dans un dîner,
on est un peu plus gai.
On ne raconte pas
les mêmes histoires
à la fin du dîner
qu’au début du dîner.
Mais pourquoi
c’est un faux ami ?
Parce que tout prouve
et toutes les études prouvent
que le fait de
consommer de l’alcool
quand on est déprimé
aggrave la symptomatologie dépressive,
augmente le risque suicidaire,
fait que la dépression
est plus difficile à traiter,
donc faux ami absolu,
il semble faire du bien,
mais en fait,
il fait du mal et il aggrave.
La dépression isole.
Quand on se met
à ne plus avoir de désir,
ne plus avoir
d’estime de soi,
on va se couper
de son travail,
parce qu’on a
du mal à travailler,
de sa famille,
de ses amis.
C’est bien pour ça
qu’il va falloir
repérer cet état
et le traiter.
Mais les liens ne sont
jamais aussi simples.
Toutes les dépressions
ne vont pas conduire,
par exemple, à une désocialisation complète,
mais il y a dans la dépression un impact social
qu’on va réduire d’autant plus qu’on peut ne pas la nier,
ne pas la dénier,
demander un avis médical
et rapidement traiter
le problème.
La dépression
est plus fréquente
à partir de 18 ou 20 ans
et chez les adultes.
On peut malgré tout
voir des dépressions
chez les enfants,
chez les adolescents.
Elle va s’exprimer
de manière différente,
par exemple, par une cassure de la prise de poids,
par des troubles
du comportement.
La dépression
est très fréquente :
10 % de la population
sur toute la vie.
La bonne nouvelle,
c’est que la dépression
peut et doit se traiter.
Sur tous les mots
de la psychiatrie,
il y a une sorte
de récupération
dans le langage général.
Vous savez,
tous nos diagnostics
de personnalité, par exemple,
sont des insultes.
Il n’y a qu’en psychiatrie
qu’on voit ça.
Si on vous traite d’hystérique, de paranoïaque,
de narcissique,
ce n’est pas un diagnostic, c’est une insulte.
Pour la dépression,
le terme de “dépression”
a été repris
dans le langage commun
sous le terme de
“déprime”.
La déprime n’a aucune définition médicale.
S’il fallait trouver
une sorte d’équivalent,
on pourrait dire que
la déprime, c’est la tristesse,
c’est l’émotion qu’on ressent de manière passagère
et qui ne doit pas être traitée.
Mais la réalité, c’est que
la notion de “déprime”
ne doit pas faire oublier
que chez certains,
qui se considèrent comme atteints de déprime,
ils sont en fait atteints d’une vraie maladie dépressive
qui doit être reconnue
et traitée.
Donc, concrètement, n’utilisons pas
ce mot “déprime”,
utilisons éventuellement
le terme de "tristesse",
qui est beaucoup plus juste pour définir une émotion,
et celui de maladie dépressive.
Quand j’étais jeune,
on parlait de
“dépression masquée”.
On disait : il y a des gens
qui n’ont pas de dépression
mais ils ont
mal quelque part,
ça doit bien cacher
une dépression.
La réalité, aujourd’hui,
telle qu’elle ressort
de nos études,
comme celles qu’on conduit dans le service ici,
montre qu’un certain nombre d’états dépressifs,
avec ce qu’on a dit,
la perte d’envie,
la perte d’estime de soi
et la fatigue,
s’accompagnent
de douleurs.
Donc dans ce cas-là,
la douleur est un peu déclenchée par la dépression
et quand on traite
la dépression,
on fait disparaître la douleur.
Mais il n’y a pas,
et c’est bien prouvé maintenant,
de dépression masquée.
Donc si on a mal aux oreilles, le nez bouché, mal à la tête,
n’allons pas imaginer
que c’est une dépression
si on n’a pas les signes
de la dépression.
Les malades psychiatriques dont je m’occupe au quotidien
subissent une double peine.
Un : ce n’est pas
des vrais malades.
Ce n’est pas comme
les malades de cardiologie,
comme les cancéreux,
qui vont mobiliser
de l’émotion, de l’empathie.
Deuxième idée fausse :
on ne les guérit pas.
C’est vrai pour l’alcoolisme
et c’est vrai
pour la dépression.
La réalité
est complètement inverse.
Un déprimé bien traité,
qui a bénéficié
d’une psychothérapie,
qui surtout en amont
a été reconnu
comme en état
de dépression,
peut être traité
et totalement guéri.
Donc ces maladies, aujourd’hui, se guérissent.
Ce qui ne se guérit pas,
c’est le déni qu’on peut avoir vis-à-vis de ces maladies,
la non-reconnaissance,
la méfiance
ou le mépris
qu’on peut avoir
soit vis-à-vis des malades, soit de ceux qui les soignent.
Si vous voulez
plus de contenu
sur la dépression
et la santé mentale,
n’hésitez pas à vous abonner à notre page YouTube.
En attendant de vous retrouver sur notre page,
nous vous disons à bientôt !
Subtitle to use, please
pay attention to the red grid